[Musique]
des personnages effectivement c'est
l'air qui est toujours célébrée à la
réunion elle était hôtesse chansonnière
et c'est une personnage qui a vécu
durant la première moitié du xixème
siècle elle est morte en en 1864 elle
tenait un relais de poste à soulac à les
salines sous la conduite de nuit de
saint paul et les gens venaient la
rencontre et puisque comme c'était un
relais de poste la diligence passait par
là les visiteurs pouvaient se reposer un
peu se désaltérer voire même se
restaurer et le temps passé dans cette
cette auberge en fin de compte qui était
une auberge célimène prenait souvent sa
guitare et puis se mettaient à
improviser chanter des des chansons et
des verts qui l'ont rendu célèbre
c'est vers effectivement on on voit une
liberté liberté ou célimène aime
s'amuser
utilisez des tournures à la fois en
français est à la fois en créole et dans
sévère il pouvait même y avoir des
critiques envers ou ses voisins
effectivement ils n'étaient pas
forcément des personnages très
sympathique voire même des notables de
l'époque qu'elle ne se permettait à
travers effectivement son écriture de se
moquer gentiment de railler un petit peu
ces personnalités et figures
c'est une jolie petite guitare pendant
tic telle qu'on pouvait les trouver donc
durant la première moitié du 19e siècle
donc une facture qui peut tout à fait
correspondre aux instruments qui étaient
fabriqués à cette époque là bas et que
c'est une guitare beaucoup plus petit
par rapport à la guitare actuelle où la
guitare classique avec des motifs
décoratifs notamment ici pour le cordier
ou voyez des moustaches qui sont
sculptés donc cette guitare
effectivement a fait l'objet d'une
restauration
ce qui permet effectivement de présenter
aujourd'hui l'instrument le mythique qui
accompagné céline elle lorsqu'elle
[Musique]